[Music]
good morning
the
8986 meeting of the security council is
called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is letter dated 28 february 2014 from
the permanent representative of ukraine
to the united nations addressed to the
president of the security council s
2014
136
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the representative of ukraine
to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting
ms rosemary de carlo under secretary
general for political and peace building
affairs and mr raphael mariano grossi
director general of the international
atomic energy agency
who is participating as you will see
from the screen on an airplane and we
hope the connection will hold it is so
decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two of the agenda
i now give the floor to ms rosemary de
carlo
[Music]
madam president
the secretary general is gravely
concerned by the escalating fighting
throughout ukraine
ukrainian cities are today under siege
and facing repeated attacks
over one million ukrainians have already
crossed ukraine's borders and have been
welcomed by their european neighbors
we applaud such solidarity and support
everyone seeking refuge should be
afforded protection without any form of
discrimination
millions of ukrainians who remain in the
country are being subjected to heavy
often indiscriminate bombardment and
shelling
there are thousands of casualties and
their number is growing
the u.n is significantly increasing its
humanitarian assistance in ukraine to
respond to the escalating crisis
madam president the secretary general
has followed with great alarm
reports of heavy fighting around the
zaparisia nuclear power plant in ukraine
we understand that the fire affected a
training facility and not the cooling
system or power center
military operations around nuclear sites
and other critical civilian
infrastructure are not only unacceptable
but highly
irresponsible
ukraine knows only too well the
devastation of a major nuclear accident
the chernobyl disaster
in 1986 stands as a lasting example of
why it is vital to ensure all nuclear
power plants have the highest standards
of safety and security
every effort should be taken to avoid a
catastrophic nuclear incident
the persistence and bravery of the
ukrainian personnel who continue to keep
power plants safely operational during
this crisis are to be applauded
madam president attacks on nuclear power
facilitaries facilities are contrary to
international humanitarian law
specifically article 56 of additional
protocol 1 to the geneva convention
states that and i quote
works or installations containing
dangerous forces namely dams dikes and
nuclear electrical generating stations
shall not be made the object of attack
even where these objects are military
objectives
if such attack may cause the release of
dangerous forces and consequent severe
losses among the civilian population
end quote
the secretary general welcomes the
statements and actions by the
international atomic energy agency on
this issue and is ready to assist
however he can
it's vital that all parties work with
the iaea to establish an appropriate
framework that will ensure the safe
secure and reliable operation of
ukraine's nuclear power plants
urgent and safe passage should be
granted to iaea personnel should they
need to travel to ukraine to work with
regulators
madam president
we welcome the reported agreement
between the ukrainian and russian
negotiators during their second round of
talks in belarus yesterday
we understand the discussion focused on
the establishment of humanitarian
corridors to allow safe passage for
civilians and the delivery of
humanitarian assistance
we hope that this reported agreement is
implemented without delay and that a
full and unconditional ceasefire is
quickly agreed and enacted
we urge the sides to continue
negotiations and to make urgent progress
on security humanitarian and other
issues
madam president as the secretary general
has emphatically stated the sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
of ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders must be respected in
line with general assembly resolutions
what we are witnessing in ukraine today
is inconsistent with the principles of
the un charter
only diplomacy and negotiations can
achieve a last truly lasting solution to
the current conflict
the fighting in ukraine must stop and it
must stop now
thank you madam president
i thank mr carlo for her briefing and i
now give the floor to mr raphael mariana
grossi
we're hoping the connection will be
working from the airplane
we cannot hear you
[Music]
we've lost uh mr grossie for the moment
we're going to start with our list of
speakers and then come back to him when
connection is re-established i'd like to
therefore invite
those council members who wish to make
statements and i give the floor to the
representative of the united kingdom you
have the floor
thank you madam president and i'd like
to thank under secretary general de
carlo for her briefing
and we look forward to hearing the
briefing from mr grossi
the united kingdom and our partners
called this urgent meeting
because russian forces
last night attacked the largest nuclear
power station in europe
we're grateful
to the ukrainian firefighters and
authorities
who got the fire under control and are
working bravely to ensure that the plant
remains safe
we support the work of the iaea in
ukraine
and are relieved that so far they have
reported that none of the safety systems
in the plant was affected
and that there was no release of
radioactive material
colleagues
this is the first time
that a state has attacked
a fueled and functioning
nuclear power plant
international law
requires special protection for nuclear
facilities
and it is difficult to see how russia's
actions were compatible with its
commitments
under article 56
of the additional protocol of the
geneva's conventions
it must not happen again
even in the midst of an illegal invasion
of ukraine
russia must keep fighting
away from
and protect the safety and security of
nuclear sites
colleagues president putin said
yesterday that the special military
operation
or as everyone else calls it the war
was going to plan
everyone
around this table knows that is not true
president putin misjudged the strength
resilience and will of the ukrainian
people
to his invasion
he underestimated the world's
condemnation of his actions
141 votes in the general assembly and
the unprecedented sanctions on russia
demonstrate the strength of the global
response
every day this war continues
the destruction it brings to ukraine
the suffering it inflicts on ukrainian
and russian people
and the risks it poses to international
peace and security
increase
this must stop
we call on russia
to end this violence
withdraw its troops
and enter into serious peace
negotiations
i thank you madam president
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for their statement
i will now try and give the floor to mr
rafael mariano grossi to give his
briefing to the council
thank you madam president i hope you can
hear me now
yes yes
can you hear me
yes
we can hear you
very good so i will try to proceed with
my briefing on the current
uh situation
in the ukraine
and especially
after the events last night we have been
in contact with the
nuclear regulation agency of the ukraine
from the very beginning
of the conflict
and we have been
raising
updates and information
from them
without interruption
in general the situation could be
described as follows
the um nuclear uh
installations
and the nuclear facilities in ukraine
are quite important
for big sites
15
reactors and associated
facilities
plus
the
site of chernobyl
regarding chernobyl already last week
we were informed and it was so confirmed
afterwards
that the russian
special military forces
took charge of the site
at the same time
the
operators of the plant
of the chernobyl
plant
continued
to
run the day by day operations
over there
a few days ago
we were informed again
by the russian
government
that military
forces were moving in the area of
surprise
nuclear power plant
with the similar mission
to take over control of this facility
we got information the sense that
their advance towards the
perimeter of the nuclear power band
was met with opposition and some
group of civilians
abstracting the access
to
the plant
finally
this happened
last night
in the
early hours of
morning we got information that a
projectile had impact
a
building
adjacent
to the block of reactors six of them
the
projectile
impact this building
and a fire ensued which was after some
time
put
out by the fire brigade
at the station
through our contacts
at the regulator but also directly from
the plant
we were able to confirm that no
security or safety systems have been
compromised
neither the reactors themselves
themselves
have been
hit
by this projectile
only as i say and repeat
this building which caught fire and
perhaps you saw some images of that
in the social media
after this
the operation
of
and at the plant
had continued
we consider from a technical point of
view
that operation continues there is no of
course normalcy about
the situation when there are military
forces of course in charge of of the
site
the
in terms of the next steps
we continue
our permanent contact
with the ukrainian authorities
governmental
nuclear regulatory and also
energo atom the company which operates
these facilities
and
also
operators there this is
or constitutes the basis of the regular
updates more than 10 or 12 at this point
which you have been seeing on the
websites of the iaea
at the same time
today
i indicated in the morning my readiness
to travel as soon as practicable to
chernobyl
in order
to consult of course with our ukrainian
counterparts but also if necessary and
when necessary to the forces in charge
in order to establish a stable framework
so the observance of the basic
principles of safety and security
starting with the physical integrity of
the facilities can be observed basic
elements of this initiative proposal
have already been shared with
the ukrainian counterparts
and
the russian authorities which are at
this point
evaluating that
we believe
that having received a direct request
for assistance it is our duty as the
iaea to hit this goal and to try to
provide assistance
needless to say in particular madam
president to your body and the
distinguished representatives over there
that this mission of the iaea
if and when it takes place would not of
course have um
anything to do with the political and
diplomatic aspects that are in the
purview of the security council this
mission would be strictly restricted and
circumscribed to the safety and security
of the nuclear installations in ukraine
which are evidently and as facts have
shown
under constant
danger
of uh damage and
accidents
so madam president i hope these basic
elements
will help you in the evaluation of the
situation
we request members of the council as i
have done
in vienna
at my board of governors to support my
efforts as director general and those of
the iaea
in order to ensure a basic element in
this
very difficult situation which is the
safety and the security
of this important infrastructure of the
country i thank you very much
madam president
ready in case there are questions or
particular points that might not be
clear to clarify them and thank you very
much and i excuse myself for the pure
quality of my connection as you know i'm
airborne now i'm on my way to tehran to
deal with another issue which is of
direct interest of the council which is
the hopefully solution of the
outstanding aspects of the nuclear power
program in the islamic republic of iran
thank you very
much i thank mr grossi for his briefing
and we'll now continue with the list of
speakers and then come back for any
questions to the briefers i now give the
floor to the representative of albania
you have the floor
thank you madam president and i'd like
to thank
the usg di carlo and um we're happy that
we could listen to the g grossi and i'd
like to reassure him of our full support
and his efforts on the issue on the map
um
the issue that we're discussing today
dear colleagues
10 days into the so-called special
operation
which in reality is the operation how to
invade your neighbor
and we are in the midst of a large-scale
human tragedy running towards an overall
catastrophe
for ukraine first
but for russia as well and as we see
every day with serious implications for
the wider europe
thousands have been killed with at least
2 000 civilians
according to unreported some 12 million
people are in urgent need of
humanitarian assistance
one million have already fled the
country the fastest and largest mass
exodus of people in conflict situations
in decades
all developments of this major
geopolitical crisis artificially created
by russia's unprovoked and unjustified
aggression against ukraine indicate
unmistakably
that it is headed towards further
escalation
overwhelming vote in the unga just two
days ago told russia that it could not
take the world hostage
unfortunately this loud call by the
world asking russia to stop its
aggression is not heard in moscow and
russia remains defiant and is stubbornly
descending into abyss
dear colleagues the world was alarmed
late last night after news of the fire
at the zappos nuclear power station
caused by russian shelling
a huge blaze on the site of europe's
biggest nuclear power station was
thankfully quickly extinguished
yet we remain greatly concerned and it
is alarming that russian forces have
captured the nuclear power plant
russia's grip on a plan that provides
more than one-fifth of ukraine's
electricity is a serious cause of
concern and could have huge
repercussions on civilians and ukraine's
economy
fighting at the plant or any other
disturbance could cause a potential
nuclear disaster radioactive damage and
have irreparable consequences for
europe's environment
it is difficult not to have in mind the
dead full images of chernobyl
we welcome the quick reactions from iaea
and the reassurance that we heard from
d.g grossi putting its incident and
emergency center in full response due to
the gravity of the situation
they should be given urgent unhindered
access to verify and monitor all the
conditions and ensure safeguards are all
in place
as the situation remains very
challenging
russian occupiers must immediately allow
unfettered access for emerging service
to the plant and whatever it's needed
we urge the iaea to continue working
closely with ukraine with a view to
providing maximum possible assistance to
the country as it seeks to maintain
nuclear safety and security in the
current difficult circumstances
it is important for the nuclear power
plant to continue to be operated by its
regular staff
we are very concerned about the reports
from the operator that the situation
remains difficult
we call on russia to end its aggression
withdraw its troop out of ukraine to
hold use of force near any nuclear power
plant and any civilian infrastructure in
general and respect article 56 of the
additional protocol of the geneva
convention
attacking civilians and civilian
infrastructure constitutes a crime
and perpetrators must and will be held
accountable
we welcome the establishment by the u.n
human rights council of an international
commission of inquiry to investigate war
crimes committed in the aggression
against ukraine
evidence must be gathered documented and
presented to the courts
we support the icc prosecutor to
investigate and document crimes
committed for the purpose of
accountability
dear colleagues
the human was not created to make
humankind
to take humankind to heaven but to save
humanity from hell
as doug hammerskill famously said
it falls upon this council to do what it
can and what is needed to save ukraine
its people and entire europe from the
hell where russia is heading to with its
relentless aggression
i thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for their statement and i now give the
floor to the representative of the
united states
thank you madam president
by the grace of god
the world narrowly averted a nuclear
catastrophe last night
we all waited to exhale as we watch the
horrific situation unfold in real
time i applaud the ability of the
ukrainian operators to keep all six
reactors in safe conditions while under
attack and to report as they were able
to their to their nuclear regulator
moreover we appreciate the state
nuclear regulatory inspectorate of
ukraine for its continuous updates to
the iaea
and to the international community
we are gravely concerned
that the ukrainian operators are now
doing their jobs
under extreme duress
russia's attack last night put europe's
largest nuclear power at grave risk
it was incredibly reckless
and dangerous
and it threatened the safety of
civilians across russia
ukraine
and europe
as a first step we call on russia to
withdraw its troops from the plant to
permit medical treatment for injured
personnel
to ensure operators have full access to
the site and are able to communicate
with nuclear regulators
and to allow the operators to conduct
shift changes to ensure the continued
safe operation of the plant
ukrainian firefighters and nuclear
engineers must have full access to the
nuclear facility to assess
damage particularly to water intake
piping and mitigate a further
deterioration
of the situation if needed
nuclear facilities cannot become part of
this conflict
reliable electricity is vital for the
nuclear facility as are backup diesel
generators and fuel
safe transit corridors must be
maintained
russia must halt any further use
of force that might put at further risk
all 15 operable reactors across ukraine
or interfere with ukraine's ability to
maintain the safety and the security of
its 37 nuclear facilities and their
surrounding populations
the united states remains highly
concerned that russian military forces
controlling the chernobyl site have not
permitted operators there to have a
shift change since last week
this is highly irresponsible behavior
and causes grave concerns for continued
safe operation
of both sites
and we call on all countries to support
iaea director general grossi
in his efforts to find arrangements
going forward to ensure nuclear safety
and prevent a nuclear catastrophe in
ukraine
over the past nine days we have
witnessed the devastating impact
impacts of president putin's war of
choice on the ukrainian people yesterday
the u.n reported that russia's invasion
had turned half a million children
into refugees
russia has killed thousands of
ukrainians and sacrificed thousand more
russian soldiers lives in the process
russia is destroying critical
infrastructure which is denying people
drinking water to stay alive and gas to
keep people from freezing to death in
the middle of winter
the humanitarian impact of this
destruction
will be significant
141 nations across the world have called
loudly and clearly on president putin to
stop this brutal unjustified unprovoked
attack
not only has he not listened
we've just witnessed a dangerous new
escalation that represents a dire threat
to all of europe and the world
to my russian counterparts
this council needs answers we need to
hear you say this won't happen again as
our uk colleague just stated
we call on you to withdraw your troops
and weaponry from ukraine
we call on you to respect ukraine's
borders its people
and the u.n charter
we call on you to respect your own
troops enough not to send them into an
unjust war
or on a suicide mission against a
nuclear power plant
we call on russia
to abide by its international law
obligations
the world demands
that russia abide by international
humanitarian law which prohibits
intentionally targeting civilians and
civilian infrastructure and allow
humanitarian agencies
full and secure access to people in need
of aid
the united states and our partners have
called for a briefing this monday on the
humanitarian situation in ukraine
we support the urgent work by
humanitarian organizations on a
humanitarian pause to allow for safe for
safe passage and the delivery of
humanitarian supplies
president putin must stop this
humanitarian catastrophe by ending this
war and ceasing these unconscionable
attacks
against the people of ukraine
mr putin must stop this madness
and he must stop it now
cooler heads must prevail
russian forces are now 20 miles and
closing from ukraine's second largest
nuclear facility
so this imminent danger continues
we narrowly avoided a disaster last
night
the international community must be
unanimous
in demanding russia's forces
stop their dangerous assault
and as i've said before
the people of ukraine are counting on us
and we must not
let them down
thank you
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement and i now give
the floor to the representative of
france
madame the president
mr grossi
carlos
proposition
foreign
mercy
i thank the representative of france for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of ireland
thank you very much madam president and
i would like to thank under secretary
general de carlo and director general
grossi for their briefings and director
general grossi's call for urgent action
today we are here
today because of our concern about the
ongoing situation
at the zapa region nuclear power plant
madam president
the russian federation's continuing
unprovoked unjustified invasion of
ukraine is wreaking havoc and
destruction on ukraine and on its people
this aggression is inflicting enormous
hardship and suffering
ireland stands full square in unwavering
solidarity with the people of ukraine
who continue to show extraordinary
courage and resilience in the face of
this act of aggression
the parties to the conflict must comply
with international humanitarian law
this includes the obligation not to
attack civilian objects it includes the
obligation and clear prohibition against
indiscriminate and disproportionate
attacks
it includes the obligation to take all
feasible precautions
in an attack we demand nothing less than
full respect for those obligations
the attack last night by russian forces
on the nuclear power plant at zapposia
has shocked us all
it has sent a chilling signal
across europe indeed across the globe
this further reinforces the concerns
arising from the armed takeover by
russia of the nuclear facilities in the
chernobyl exclusion zone just eight days
ago
ireland condemns the reckless firing
against nuclear power plants
armed attacks and threats against
nuclear facilities devoted to peaceful
purposes
constitute violations of international
law
including the principles of the un
charter
additional protocol one to the geneva
conventions and the iaea statute and
director general grossi has made that
point abundantly clear
in attacking such sites the russian
federation risks an environmental
disaster
compounding the extraordinary human
tragedy we are witnessing today in
ukraine
a radioactive release from any of these
sites
would also have serious repercussions
for human life and health
for agriculture
and for the environment in ukraine
in the russian federation itself
and the wider european region
president we call on the russian
federation to fully respect its
obligations under the u.n charter
international law and the iaea statute
all
international nuclear safety and
security standards must be maintained
we call on the russian federation to
allow ukrainian personnel at the plant
to do their work safely and without
undue pressure
it is crucial
that safety systems at the plant are not
compromised
power supplied to the plant must be
maintained
this is essential not just for the six
reactors at the site but also for the
spent fuel stored there
there should be no interruption of basic
services including energy to the
population across ukraine
ireland commends the bravery and the
professionalism of the ukrainian
personnel at the plant
and the ukrainian nuclear regulator in
seeking to ensure safety at the plant in
very difficult circumstances
we are deeply concerned however for
their safety and their well-being
at this worrying time
ireland fully supports the work of the
iaea and its incident and emergency
center in its ongoing monitoring and
assistance in respect of the nuclear
safety and security situation in ukraine
we believe it will be important for the
iaea director general to keep this
council informed regarding nuclear
safety and security in ukraine
[Music]
president
cavalier
reckless behavior with dangerous forces
such as nuclear power
is unacceptable it's utterly
unacceptable
the prospect of a nuclear event
at europe's largest nuclear power plant
will have global impacts
we all saw what happened at chernobyl
and fukushima
this is a specter no one at this table
should be willing to countenance
madam president the humanitarian
implications of damage to civilian
infrastructure cannot be underestimated
the electricity generated by zaparija
power powers homes
and hospitals
ensuring that civilians can feed and
heat themselves
powering life-saving medical equipment
let's be clear
civilian infrastructure should never be
a target
and it must stop now
mr president once more ireland urges the
russian federation to immediately cease
all hostilities
to unconditionally withdraw from the
entire territory of ukraine
and to refrain from further threats or
the use of force of any kind against
ukraine or indeed any other member state
to avert nuclear disaster
ireland today calls most urgently for an
immediate
cessation of military activities at
ukraine's nuclear facilities
we call for the competent ukrainian
authorities to be allowed to promptly
regain full control over zaparija and
all their nuclear facilities
one more time madam president
we call sincerely for a return to
dialogue and diplomacy in good faith
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of ireland
for their statement and i now give the
floor to the representative of norway
president
i thank under secretary general de carlo
and director general grossi for their
briefing to the council
and i also thank iaea for providing
frequent factual updates on matters
within the agency's mandate
we call this meeting with partners
because
president
this is an unjust war
unjustly fought
norway condemns the russian federation's
invasion of ukraine
and now as reported we see shelling and
fighting in the immediate vicinity of a
civilian nuclear power plant
it takes little imagination to
understand the possible consequences of
such action
it shows a blatant disregard for
ukrainian lives
for russian lives and indeed life in
europe and beyond
it is irresponsible and unacceptable
civilians can never be a target
a new nuclear power plant can never be a
target
yet this is only the latest in a string
of assaults on homes hospitals schools
bridges roads and other vital civilian
infrastructure
damage and destruction of a nuclear
plant would put us all in danger it can
lead to a radioactive nightmare with the
most severe long-term effects for
generations
president
international humanitarian law is not
optional
we call on russia to fulfill its
obligation to protect civilians and
civilian infrastructure
these actions also violate the
obligation under ihl
to maintain the physical integrity of
nuclear facilities
and keep them safe at all times
and we recall the decision of the iaea
general conference from 2009 that and i
quote any armed attack
on the threat against nuclear facilities
devoted to peaceful purposes constitutes
a violation of the principles of the
united nations charter international law
and the statute of the agency unquote
we commend the efforts of the state
nuclear regulatory inspectorate of
ukraine to keep the international
community updated on the status of
nuclear safety and security in their
country
and our thoughts go to the staff the men
and women working at nuclear facilities
in ukraine under these dire
circumstances
we load their commitments to ensuring
continuing nuclear safety and security
their perseverance is an example to us
all
president russia bears full
responsibility for this act of
aggression and all the destruction and
loss of life it has and will continue to
cause
we reiterate
our call upon the russian federation to
immediately withdraw its forces from
ukraine ukrainian territory and sees all
threats and military actions including
in the vicinity of and directed at
nuclear facilities
a ceasefire is desperately and urgently
needed
diplomacy must win thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
their statement
i give the floor to the representative
of the russian federation
gospel
ukraine
b
is
my microphone doesn't work
my
let's try another one
can you speak can we try
is
is
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
great
foreign
is
foreign
foreign
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for their statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of india
thank you madam president
i thank usd de carlo
and d.g grossi for their briefings
it is regrettable that the situation in
ukraine has worsened further
since the council last convened on this
matter
an immediate secession of violence
and end to all hostilities are essential
we continue to carefully follow the
developments regarding the safety and
security of ukraine's nuclear power
reactors and facilities
india attaches the highest importance
to ensuring safety and security of
nuclear facilities as any accident
involving the nuclear facilities
may have severe consequences for public
health and the environment
india accords the highest priority to
the discharged by the iaea of its
safeguards and monitoring activities in
accordance with its statute in an
effective
non-discriminatory and efficient manner
we have also noted the latest
information available with regard to the
nuclear power plants and facilities in
ukraine including today's updates
provided by the dg iaea on the current
situation
madam president while we are discussing
the nuclear dimension of an unfolding
conflict
this council must acknowledge that there
is a pressing humanitarian crisis
confronting us in in ukraine where
safety and security of innocent
civilians including several thousand
indian nationals in particular students
are at stake
we therefore hope that the second round
of talks between the two sides
contributes to the immediate
establishment of a safe humanitarian
corridor
as reiterated by my prime minister and
his conversations with global leaders
including of the russian federation and
ukraine differences must be resolved
through sustained dialogue and diplomacy
commitment to the principles of the u.n
charter to international law and respect
for the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of all states are key
principles in this regard i thank you
i thank the representative of india for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of mexico you have
the floor
gracias
is
pacificos
ambient
a
i thank the representative of mexico for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of ghana
thank you madam president
i wish to thank you for convening this
emergency session of the security
council at this critical moment in the
situation in ukraine and also thank usg
de carlo and director general grossi for
the information provided
ghana is gravely concerned about the
intensifying military escalations across
several cities in ukraine in particular
with the attack and shelling of sites
close to nuclear power plants and
facilities
it is a relief to learn that the
situation at the zaporicha nuclear plant
is currently stable and the radioactive
emissions remain within accepted range
every effort must be made to mitigate
the risk of accidental emissions which
pose immeasurable risk to the lives of
civilians in an already fragile
environment
we urge the continued support of the
iaea to provide necessary assistance to
the ukrainian authorities to ensure the
safety and security of nuclear
installations and staff present on site
we cannot forget too soon the horrors of
the 1986 chernobyl accident and the
consequent nuclear
catastrophe which left in its wake
long-term effects of radiation exposure
to many people in ukraine and parts of
europe even to date ghana strongly
appeals to the parties to exercise
restraints and to halt the use of force
in all areas of critical infrastructure
including the nuclear power plants and
to respect their international
obligations to protect human lives and
to prevent potential disasters
we take note of the ongoing diplomatic
talks between the parties in belarus and
welcome the agreements reached to create
a humanitarian corridor to allow for the
evacuation of the millions of people
caught up in the crossfires as well as
the considerations to provide food and
medical supplies
together with the international
community we express our strong support
for the peaceful resolution of this
conflict
and urge further constructive engagement
by the parties at all levels in the
pursuit of their security interests and
the maintenance of international peace
and security i thank you
i thank the representative of ghana for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of china
well
father
[ __ ]
foreign
i thank the representative of china for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of brazil
thank you madam president
madam president i would like to thank
you for convening this meeting and
usg rosemary dicarlo and dg rafael
grossi
for their presentations
we commend and support the international
atomic energy agency
for remaining in constant contact with
authorities in ukraine
and for fully discharging technical
responsibilities and functions
as per the agency's statute and related
instruments
we commend the agency's director general
for his offer to visit ukraine and for
his efforts to secure a commitment by
all parties
to ensure the safety and security of
nuclear facilities in the country
now i am almost embarrassed to reiterate
that we are facing unprecedented
dire circumstances
we are not only witnessing an appalling
humanitarian catastrophe in ukraine
but now are also confronted with the
prospect of a nuclear incident
of significant dimensions
due to the situation
in the nuclear facility in zappos
this is one more reason for the
international community to strenuously
call for an immediate and comprehensive
cessation of all hostilities in ukraine
we are under threat of a radioactive
incident of major proportions
which could have enormous consequences
not only for ukraine but for all of
europe
the complete de-escalation
in that regard we appreciate usg dicarlo
for drawing attention of the council to
article 56 of the first additional
protocol to the geneva con conventions
according to which
nuclear electrical generating stations
shall not be made the object of attack
even where these objects are military
objectives
if such attack may cause the release of
dangerous forces and consequent severe
losses among the civilian population
allow me to add that the article
also applies to and i quote
other military objectives
located at or in the vicinity of those
works or installations
end quote
the iaea general conference has adopted
a number of decisions
on the protection of nuclear
installations devoted to peaceful
purposes against armed attacks
prohibition of attacks and threat of
attack there too
these decisions must be respected at all
times
brazil calls on all parties to refrain
from any measure or action
that could jeopardize the security of
nuclear materials
as well as the safe operation of all
nuclear facilities in ukraine as any
such incident
could have severe and enduring
consequences for human health and the
environment
madam president
well expressed whilst expressing grave
concern on the recent developments
we cannot turn a blind eye
to the role that the council should play
but is not playing in the current
situation
a number of meetings have been held in
this chamber
on the situation in ukraine
it seems that no matter how many public
meetings we convene
a ceasefire and the end of hostilities
remain
elusive this is not a paradox but rather
a warning on the failure of the council
to act constructively in addressing the
matter
brazil urges all members here to truly
and actively engage
to promote dialogue and rebuild trust
the general assembly resolution recently
adopted
urged russia and ukraine
to seek a peaceful resolution of the
conflict through political dialogue
negotiations mediation and other
peaceful means
this is not the time to further escalate
the rhetoric
but to engage in conversations towards
peace
there is an array of instruments
available to the council and to the
parties under chapter 6 of the un
charter
the security council has
we have
the responsibility to create an
environment
conducive to a ceasefire and to lasting
peace
at this moment
we reiterate our appeal for a ceasefire
and most of all for diplomacy
i thank you madam president
i thank the representative of brazil for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of kenya
thank you madam president
i thank usg dicarlo and director general
grossi
for their briefings
kenya is deeply concerned about the
reports made yesterday of a fire in the
closed vicinity of sapporo ricia nuclear
power plant in ukraine
it is with relief that we learned from
the international atomic energy agency
that the reactor safety
systems have not been affected and that
radioactive material
has not been released
there are a few dangerous
installations containing dangerous
forces the nuclear plants in regard to
catastrophic humanitarian and
environmental consequences of their
destruction
on this occasion
good fortune intervened to safeguard the
reactor
however the fact that the armed conflict
is still underway
and features extensive ground
air and sea military operations means
that the risk
still remains unacceptably high
missed
madam president
rarely have international conventions
regulating the conduct of armed conflict
been more urgent
to observe
we therefore call for a clearance of the
protocol additional to the geneva
conventions of august 1949
relating to the protection of victims
of
non-international armed conflicts
protocol 2 particularly part 4.
article 15 states and i quote
works or installations containing
dangerous forces namely dams dikes
and nuclear electrical generating
stations shall not be made
the object of attack even where the
objects are military objectives
if such attack may cause the release of
dangerous forces and consequent severe
loss
losses among the civilian population
kenya also recalls the resolution
adopted last april
on protection of objects indispensable
to survival of civilian population
which highlights the significant effect
the destruction of essential
infrastructure in many conflicts across
the globe
continues to have on civilians
beyond the risk to nuclear plants we add
due caution to be taken in any action
that may destroy civilian objects that
are critical to the survival of the
ukrainians
armed to them can lead to an escalation
of the armed conflict and make it all
more difficult to resolve it
madam president
kenya calls for military leaderships of
ukraine and the russian federation
to establish mechanisms to reduce the
targeting
and risk to critical infrastructure such
a mechanism
can mirror the agreement made yesterday
by both sides of conflict to establish a
humanitarian corridor as well as
temporary
local ceasefire to enable aid deliveries
we encourage the continuation of this
positive dialogue and call on the
russian federation to urgently enter
negotiations to settle this conflict by
peaceful means
finally madam president
we take note of the resolution adopted
yesterday
by the
iaea board of governors we thank the
director general for his regular updates
and the continuing efforts
to ensure safety and security in all
facilities
in the country i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
their statement and i shall now make a
statement in my capacity as the
representative of the united arab
emirates i thank under secretary general
rosemary de carlo and director general
rafael grossi for their briefings
my country is also following the
situation at the zafarita nuclear power
plant with deep concern the reports that
we have received about fires affecting
the plants suggest a dangerous
development in the conflict the
humanitarian and environmental
catastrophe resulting from a serious
nuclear incident would be hard to
contain and recovery would be difficult
we remember clearly fukushima and
chernobyl and the human costs are indeed
incalculable on both human health and
the environment
we must all prevent such accidents
happening again the parties therefore
must ensure the safety of the plant as
well as its reactors they must also
ensure the plant and the surrounding
area are not a target and remain
protected from conflict as damage to the
plant could lead to dire consequences
for the entire region and for this
reason we urge all relevant parties
involved to cooperate with the iaea to
ensure and protect the safety of nuclear
facilities in ukraine and to establish a
stable framework on the ground
there are clear reasons for having
special pure humanity the council must
make every possible effort to avoid any
kind of nuclear disaster whether from
direct attack on a nuclear facility or
as an unintended consequence of conflict
such a disaster would have grave
ramifications for generations to come
with regards to the conflict today we
again reiterate our call for a cessation
of hostilities for de-escalation and for
dialogue mechanisms to be leveraged and
to be supported by all of us the risks
of a failure in diplomacy are too grave
to consider thank you
i shall now resume my function as
president of the council and i now give
the floor to ms rosemary de carlo to
respond to any comments and questions
thank you thank you very much madam
president i'd like to respond to the
comment of the permanent representative
of russia
who referred to u.n vehicles being
requisitioned
in chromatorsk
there are at the present no u.n staff in
chromatorsk
13 vehicles were left there
and
at 10 45 this morning
the un department of safety and security
spoke with guards at the compound they
confirmed that all 13 vehicles remain
there thank you
i thank mr carlo for the clarification
she has provided
and i now give the floor to the
representative of ukraine
madam president
under secretary general dicarlo
director general
well first of all i would like to
express my gratitude for immediate
reaction
by the under secretary general
for to the lies by the russian
representative
but we are all customs accustomed to the
lies
we have survived the night that could
have stopped the history of ukraine and
europe said the president of ukraine
this morning
indeed every day provides us with new
and new evidence that
it is not only ukraine on the russian
attack
it is europe
it is the entire world
it is humanity
and finally it is the future of the next
generations
russia seems to be furious that its
plans to quickly invade ukraine have
already failed
russia is furious that the ukrainian
people
continues to
courageously fight for its freedom
russia is furious about the worldwide
solidarity with ukraine
in retaliation russia has resorted to
war crimes and crimes against humanity
russia does not even try to hide them
residential areas of ukrainian cities
and villages across the country are
being ruined by russian bombs
shells
and missiles
peaceful civilians are being killed
critical infrastructure totally damaged
just yesterday russian airstrikes killed
47 peaceful residents
of the city of chernihiv including
children
but it is not enough for russia or
terror russia
as we may already call it
because yesterday they committed an act
of nuclear terrorism while shelling and
seizing the zaparisian nuclear power
plant
in the town of nergadar
the lies by
the
permanent representative of russia are
not surprising he
may not be properly informed by his
capital
and we saw it on
on many occasions in the security
council he had no idea
what his capital was the president
was planning to do in the middle of one
of the recent sessions
so i wouldn't really rely on his wards
as a result of the shelling on the
territory of the nuclear power plant
a fire broke out killing and injuring
several people
the zaparisia npp
site as well as the chernobyl nuclear
power plant are currently under the
control of the russian armed
forces employees of these apparition
nuclear power plant are monitoring the
condition
of power units and ensuring their
operation
in accordance with the requirements of
the technical regulations for safe
operation
it is alarming that several employees
responsible for maintaining nuclear
security at the site
have reportedly been killed by russian
soldiers there has been no rotation of
personnel since yesterday morning
the building of unit 1 main building is
damaged
the overpass of the special building is
damaged
the telephone line connection is
disrupted and not available at the
moment
the state of the power units now is as
follows
unit 1 is in outage
its main building is damaged the
overpass of the special building is
damaged
unit 2 and units 2 and 3 have been
disconnected from the greed
and the cooldown of the nuclear
installations is being carried out unit
4 is in operation of 690 megawatts power
units 5 and 6 are being cooled down
state nuclear safety inspectors of the
state inspectorate for nuclear
regulation of ukraine are not allowed
access
to the zaparisia npp site
changes in the radiation situation have
not been registered
data from the automated radiation
monitoring system of this upper asia npp
does not work
cooling of the nuclear fuel within
zapalija npp power units is maintained
by dedicated systems of power units in
accordance with the requirements of
technical regulations for safe operation
if at any point the cooling process is
disturbed
this could cause radioactive damage
across large territories and have
irreparable consequences for the
environment of the entire continent
thousands of people including civilians
who are currently unable to evacuate
the area near the plant due to ongoing
shelling and
fighting would be affected
now paralyzed of the
russian ambassador
about the foreign students
an appalling example of god's lighting
example of what he probably intended to
present as almost an angelic message of
peace
but let me remind him and remind all of
us
that satan
was also an angel
an angel that rebelled against god
so i would like to ask the permanent
representative of the russian federation
if he still is able to communicate with
his capital
which is probably not the case who knows
please make an appeal
to the armed forces to ensure a safe
corridor
to allow the foreign students to leave
the areas of concern
stop spreading the lies
and you know it very well what is going
on there if you are indeed in contact
with your capital
as a result of a nuclear disaster of
this scale
may exceed if it happens god forbid
all previous accidents at nuclear power
plants including chernobyl and the
fukushima
nuclear power plants disasters
russia has deliberately undertaken an
armed attack on a nuclear power site
an action that violated all
international agreements within the iaea
in particular the iaea charter the joint
convention and the safety of spanned
fuel management
and on the safety of radioactive waste
management
the conventional nuclear accident
warning and the convention on the
protection of nuclear accidents and the
convention
on the protection of nuclear facilities
and nuclear material
the shelling of this upper asia npp is
also a gross violation of the treaty on
the non-proliferation of nuclear weapons
and the international convention for the
suppression of acts of nuclear terrorism
we are disappointed by the reaction of
the iaea
whose statement did not go as far as to
include
any mention of the attacking side
we demand clear and
decisive action from the iaea
the international community must respond
adequately to the actions of the russian
federation
which could lead to an unprecedented
nuclear catastrophe
all russian forces must be withdrawn
from the nuclear power plant
today i have sent a letter to the
secretary to the security council
president
reminding of the council's decisions on
no-fly zone during previous conflicts
in order to prevent further civilian
casualties
protect the civilian population from air
attacks
including those who are
humanitarian personnel
ensure access of humanitarian assistance
and evacuation
in this regard we request to consider
the issue of protection of nuclear power
plants and other critical infrastructure
in ukraine
urgent discussion on establishing a ban
on all flights in the airspace of
ukraine should be a top priority for the
security council
we would also like to remind that
ukraine on march 30th
2015
requested the deployment of an
international peacekeeping and security
operation in the territory of ukraine
the document s
slash 2015-225
with the exact modalities to be defined
in consultations with the ukrainian side
taking into account that russia's armed
forces could not be a part of the
peacekeeping contingent because it is
exactly the occupation armed forces that
should be separated to maintain a
ceasefire and peace
failure of the security council
to act and especially due to the
position of the russian federation
as a party to the conflict would be a
historical responsibility of the
security council and the entire
organization
distinguished members of security
council
i ought to ask the under secretary
general dicarlo
to forward our request to the secretary
general guterres
to ensure
that every single body of the united
nations
every employee of the secretariat
respects the decision of the
general assembly of march 2
and does not deviate or substitute
with ambiguities
or fakes like special military forces
the language of the resolution
that is called aggression against
ukraine
[Music]
a week
of full-fledged russian invasion
has already resulted in thousands killed
over a million refugees
ruined infrastructure
it is already the common duty of the
international community to stop russian
murderers and terrorists
stop by closing the skies over ukraine
stop by supporting ukraine in terms of
security and humanitarian assistance
stop by expelling russians from
international institutions as they do
not deserve to be among civilized and
responsible
nations
einstein said
the world will not be destroyed by those
who do evil
the ukrainians will do will deal with
evil
but by those who watch them without
doing
anything
the people of ukraine do more than they
they can do including by paying the
ultimate price
paying with their lives
and still
shameless shamefully
[Music]
there is a handful of those around us
or among us rather
who do nothing
act now
or it might be too late
not only for ukraine
but for all of you
i thank you
i thank the representative of ukraine
for their statement there are no more
names inscribed on the list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]